خرج محمود اللاجئ السوري الى الحياه مجددا
مع زوجته واطفاله الثلاثه بعد فتره زمنيه
قضوها تحت انقاض بيتهم الذي انهار من شده
الزلزال في مدينه اصلاحيه بغاز عنتاب
جنوبي تركيا
شالت الولد الصغير يحطته بحضنه وانا حطيت
اولادي هدول الاثنين وسام وسيم حطيتهم
وحطيت راس مرتي هيك وبست راسي على الارض
ونزل السقف علينا ورجعت صارت تصير هزي
كمان يعني تحت الارض ضلينا فتره يعني
الفتره والله ايش قد بالضبط يعني ما بعرف
قديش اجاني صوت يعني صوت اتراك اني بقولو
تمام تمام يعني
على البيت وسط دائره الخوف ورائحه موت
منبعثه من الجوار بات لزاما على محمود ان
يمسك بخطوط الحياه المتبقيه ويحاول
النجاه لو صرت اضرب يمين ويسار مد ايدي
يعني بدي انقذ حالي انقذ الاولاد يطلع لي
حيطان يعني
بعدين طلع لي صخره كبيره حجره ما بعرف شو
صرت تهزه واخذه وجيبها وهيك اخذه وجيبها
وتفشتها نزلت وين بالارض وين نزلت والله
ما بعرف وفتح الطريق شوي طريق فتح لكنه
غير كاف للخروج من قعر الركام الذي كاد ان
يتحول لقبر لولا اراده الحياه وانا ومنبطح
يعني
ما في عشره سنتي فوق راسي يعني حيط سقف
وعم بزحف وبطلع صرت افتح طريق وشيل بلوك
وما بعرف ايش اغراض وكركبي وقزيز وشيل عزل
الطريق هون طبعا كلياته انا بطني يعني
طلعت هيك شفت اجاني مثل اجاني هواء يعني
شميت هوا شميت هاي مثل اذا شفت السماء مثل
الحلم ضو ما بعرف يعني ما بتذكر بالضبط
ايش بس قلت ان شاء الله فرجت ان شاء الله
بدنا نطلع وصرت معزل الحجر وبلوك وشيل من
قدامي وامشي
اطلعت هيك لقيت الشباك لقيت الشباك مكسور
كله مطعوج اذا نافذه وحيده للحياه ستنقل
هذه العائله من ضفه الموت الى ضفه اخرى
وشفت السيخ سيخ الشباك مطعوج كماجته طلعت
الحمد لله رب العالمين طلع مكسور من طرف
واحد
صوره الويو بايدي طبعا انا متشطح يعني
طالعوا من فوق راسي هيك بياخدوا بجيبوا
للسيخ مشان يعني بس ينكسر معي ما انكسر بس
الا والحمد لله وطلعت فاتحه يعني هيك
فاتحه هيك يعني الحمد لله رب العالمين
يعني شيء خلصت حالي انا والاولاد
الحياه اعطت هذه العائله فرصه جديده لكنها
لم تعطي عوائل اخرى تلك الفرصه الموت
تلقفهم تحت اطنان من الركام والالم
وصرخات الانيم زيدان زنجلو العربيه من
مدينه اصلاحيه غازي عنتاب